hyperinflation food shortages power cuts
and political turmoil are just some of
the major reasons why Venezuela is kind
of screwed so how did the country that
boasts the world's largest oil reserves
get into such a mess well it pretty much
comes down to oil and a healthy dose of
US involvement but as well as economy is
heavily reliant on oil which makes up
around 95 percent of the country's
export earnings but oil prices have been
falling drastically for the last two
years hitting the lowest point in more
than a decade this has left the
government struggling to pay for imports
including basics like food and medical
supplies to make matters worse oil
prices are showing no signs of
rebounding and recent talks amongst
oil-producing countries fail to come to
an agreement to reduce output the result
empty shelves and stores
long lines for food and sparsely stocked
fridges Venezuela's currency may be the
ball of our Forte but the dollar is
still King because it's strong and
stable but it's also in short supply
meaning most Venezuelans have to use a
black market system to obtain it by
speculation so people buy dollars at a
ridiculous price because they think it's
only gonna go one way which is up when
the black market percent dollar goes up
in force become more expensive that
makes inflation worse with levels
expected to hit over 700 percent this
year president Nicolas Maduro government
has often blamed the u.s. for waging an
economic war against Venezuela
yes enormous role in destabilizing for
more than 14 years the US has been
accused of pushing for a change of
leadership in the country and funding
opposition led coup attempt since 2002
even the weather doesn't seem to be on
Venezuela's side amongst the other
turmoil the country is experiencing
drought which experts are blaming on El
Nino low water levels mean that the
country's massive hydroelectric dam is
not producing enough electricity this
has led to blackouts planned electricity
cuts and even a shorter work week of
just two days for public sector workers
to reduce energy consumption the country
even changed the clocks to add an extra
30 minutes of sunlight
so where does this leave Venezuela well
facing political turmoil late last year
the opposition gained a large majority
of the country's National Assembly for
the first time in 16 years that means
the government could face gridlock as it
tries to tackle mounting economic
struggles and that just means more
problems for the people of Venezuela